[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مظاهره وسط العاصمه تونس
لجبهه الخلاص للمطالبه بالافراج عن
المعتقلين ورئيس الجبهه يؤكد التمسك
بالعوده الى المسار الديمقراطي ويدعو الى
الوحده في وجه ما وصفه بالانقلاب في حين
قالت وزاره الداخليه ان قوات الامن امنت
المظاهره رغم رفض منظمها قرار لتونس بمنع
تنظيمها بعد اعلان مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه من طهران رفضه اي هجوم
عسكري على المنشاه النوويه نتنياهو يصف
تصريحات بعديمه الجدوى ويقول ان اسرائيل
ستواصل الدفاع عن نفسها بينما نفى الطيران
الاتفاق مع الوكاله الدوليه على تركيب
كاميرا مراقبه جديده في منشاتها النوويه
حريق كبير يلتهم مخيما للاجئين الروهنديه
في مدينه كوكس بازار جنوب شرقي بنجلاديش
منظمه
البنغلاديشيه تقدر عدد المتضررين من
الحريق باثني عشر الف لاجئ بعد احتراق
اكثر من 2000 من خيام ومساكن اللاجئين
الخشبيه الى اللقاء